imagina que pudieras comprar acciones de
la granja de tu primo
ah
a suponer que tu primo vive en un pueblo
y tiene un establo con vacas y que tú
puedes comprar acciones de esa empresa
de la misma forma en la que puedes
invertir en telefónica o en google he
vuelto loco para nada ahora mismo vais a
entender a lo que me refiero
[Aplausos]
[Música]
imagina que quieres montar una empresa
una empresa tradicional por ejemplo una
explotación ganadera en la que vas a
tener unas vacas que te produzcan leche
y es lo primero que necesitas dinero
verdad tendrás que comprar el terreno el
establo y las vacas
[Música]
pues bien de dónde puede sacar ese
dinero la primera opción sería ir al
banco y pedir un préstamo pero eso tiene
varios problemas lo primero es que si ya
de por si es arriesgado montar una
empresa con un préstamo de por medio
puedes terminar arruinado y encima con
una deuda que devolver y todo esto
suponiendo que el señor de la oficina
esté dispuesto a darte el préstamo si
habéis intentado pedir un préstamo para
montar una empresa alguna vez ya sabéis
lo difícil que puede ser convencer al
banco así que nada descartamos el banco
la siguiente opción es buscarnos un
inversor de riesgo
[Música]
ya sabéis uno de esos que viven en
silicon valley gente con muchísimo
dinero dispuesta a asociarse con jóvenes
talentos quién sabe cuál es ese pequeño
establo se puede convertir en un nuevo
gigante arriba pero a ver pero momento
core desde algún inversor a no ser que
vivas en sillicon valley o que tengas
muy buenas conexiones es difícil que
encuentras a uno de esos angel investors
de los que tanto se habla en los
periódicos vale tachamos a los bancos
tachamos a los inversores que nos quedan
tus padres no tienen suficiente dinero
oye tengo una idea y si tu nueva empresa
pudiera cotizar en bolsa
ya sabes en el mercado de valores el
sitio donde está telefónica endesa o el
banco santander lo bueno que tiene la
bolsa es que no necesitas encontrar a un
inversor millonario puedes conseguir que
cientos de personas particulares compren
acciones de tu empresa es decir que
divide su empresa en vamos a decir diez
mil acciones y las sacas al mercado por
un precio de vamos a poner diez euros
cada uno de esta forma todo el mundo
independientemente de donde viva puede
invertir en tu empresa a lo mejor hay un
señor que vive en albacete en españa y
que compra una acción otro que vamos a
decir vive en cuzco en perú y compra
diez acciones de esta forma sin tener
contactos ni tener que convencer a un
banquero puedes recaudar el dinero que
necesites solo tienes que tener una
buena idea suena fantástico verdad
[Música]
espera un momento porque hay un problema
de entrada para poder cotizar en la
bolsa por ejemplo en la bolsa de madrid
tu empresa necesita contar con un
capital social de al menos un millón
doscientos mil euros y este es sólo uno
más de los muchísimos requisitos que
tienes que cumplir
pues bien esta es la situación en la que
se encontraban los chicos del ajo huesca
ya agricultural company unos chicos que
vivían en rusia y que querían montar una
explotación ganadera y como diríais que
recaudaron el dinero pues atentos a la
noticia
i
la empresa rusa jo jo los que haya
agricultural company va a lanzar una y
ccoo para crear una cripto moneda
llamada 1000 coin con la que financiar
una granja lechera habéis oído bien
estos ganaderos crearon su propia cripto
divisa es decir algo así como su propia
versión de bitcoin lo anunciaron en una
página web y sacaron a la venta estas
nuevas monedas esto es lo que se llama
una oferta pública de divisas o por sus
siglas en inglés una y ccoo y diréis
pero y por qué alguien iba a querer
comprar otra cripto divisa no tenemos ya
bastante con el bitcoin bueno a primera
vista podría parecer que estaban
comprando cripto divisas pero realmente
estaban comprando algo parecido a
acciones de esta nueva empresa y todo
esto sin tener que pasar por la bolsa
tradicional al final de este vídeo os
contaremos lo que pasa con esta empresa
pero lo cierto es que no es el único
ejemplo hay muchos pero que muchos más
aunque sólo el 48% de los chicos del año
pasado cumplieron sus objetivos las
startups ya han conseguido recaudar más
de 5.600 millones de dólares si amigos
de visual política ya hay un nuevo
método de conseguir dinero para montar
una empresa y está disponible para
cualquiera pero esperad un momento
porque no todo es tan bonito como os
podéis imaginar todo esto de la psico
suena como un paraíso para los
estafadores y la gente de malvivir así
que la pregunta es de verdad podemos
fiarnos de este nuevo método de crear
empresas y que tiene que ver suiza en
todo esto hoy vamos a responder a estas
preguntas pero antes vamos a ver un poco
de historia
monedas versus tokens en el año 2013
bitcoin ya era una moneda conocida sobre
todo en el mundo tecnológico en sillicon
valley ya se celebraban eventos y mesas
redondas sobre el futuro de esta divisa
y en una de estas mesas redondas
apareció un señor que se llamaba j r
women
[Música]
este hombre tenía una idea muy curiosa
según él se podrían crear monedas
alternativas a bitcoin que usando la
misma tecnología pudieran tener reglas
distintas y como pagamos a los
informáticos que diseñen estos nuevos
sistemas pues en lugar de buscar un
inversor de riesgo él podía vender unos
bonos lo que llamamos un token que más
adelante se podrían canjear por la nueva
moneda y así es como surgió la primera y
ccoo de la historia
[Música]
pero antes de continuar tenemos que
hacer un paréntesis muchos os estaréis
preguntando pero pero qué es esto del
toque pues bien los token son cualquier
elemento que se puede intercambiar en
una blocks en las 30 monedas por ejemplo
serían una clase de toque pero hay otras
dos más por un lado tenemos los que
otorgan un derecho a su portador por
ejemplo este sería el caso de los bonos
que podríamos canjear por una cripto
moneda que se creara en el futuro pero
por el otro lado también tenemos los
tokens que están basados en un activo
este sería el caso por ejemplo de las
acciones de la empresa de ganaderos
rusos tener uno de sus tokens equivale a
tener un porcentaje de la propiedad de
su granja pues bien estas ofertas
públicas de tokens se pusieron de moda
en el año 2014 porque qué pasó en el año
2014 pues este es el año en el que salió
al mercado la segunda cripto moneda más
famosa que existe en el mundo
es decir yum la plataforma
descentralizada que podría reemplazar a
las instituciones actuales
a diferencia de bitcoin todos podemos
saber quién está detrás de ternium se
trata de una empresa que no sólo tiene
una cripto moneda sino que también
ofrece un sistema para que otros puedan
crear sus propios tokens por ejemplo os
acordáis de este otro vídeo en el que os
contábamos que el bbv está usando block
change para dar préstamos
[Música]
ternium es la plataforma sobre la que
trabajan pero no sólo hablamos del bbva
en realidad son muchos los que ya están
utilizando este sistema para hacer toda
clase de cosas en block change y una de
esas cosas son las chicos
la fiebre es decir yum se desata las
cinco son la moda en el mundo de la
inversión tecnológica desde entonces hay
un montón de empresas que se están
financiando con este método por ejemplo
shirín lapse es una empresa suiza que
está a punto de sacar su propio modelo
de smartphone esta empresa ha conseguido
más de 118 millones de dólares gracias a
una de las chicos más exitosas de la
historia y por supuesto hay toda clase
de empresas de internet que están
naciendo con este sistema pero esperad
un momento porque no todo es tan bonito
las chicos no tienen ninguna regulación
así que ya os podéis imaginar el resto
cómo crear una estafa con una eco en
cinco sencillos pasos y os preguntaréis
pero qué diferencia hay entre una y ccoo
y por ejemplo una página estilo
kickstarter pues muy sencillo cuando tú
apoyas un proyecto en kickstarter no
puedes vender ninguna participación en
una eco sin embargo puedes comprar tu
token o tu cripto moneda y si sube su
continuación venderla como si estuvieras
en la bolsa sólo que aquí no hay ninguna
policía financiera ni comisión del
mercado de valores que persiga los
estafadores
así que ya os podéis imaginar la
cantidad de incautos que querían dar el
pelotazo y han terminado en la ruina por
ejemplo conocido era una empresa que
quería mejorar las compras hechas con
bitcoin todo era muy bonito muy
tecnológico y muy 2.0
y consiguieron recaudar hasta
cuatrocientos mil dólares en una y ccoo
para sacar adelante este proyecto y una
vez conseguido que creéis que pasó pues
que la empresa desapareció del mapa y
como no había ningún registro público ni
nada parecido es casi imposible
perseguir a su dueño
de hecho seguro que todos habréis visto
algún anuncio que vende monedas tokens y
no sé qué más en el que te prometen
ganancias ilimitadas para que os hagáis
una idea hasta el mismo ceo de ternium
vitalic butter in reconoce que casi
todos los chicos son estafas y como os
podéis imaginar los gobiernos ya han
empezado a actuar
china ha prohibido tajantemente las
chicos en eeuu parece que van a seguir
un camino similar y en otros sitios como
estonia han dicho que vale que se pueden
hacer y cause pero los ciudadanos
estonios no pueden participar es algo
así como decir vale podéis estafar a
quien queráis menos a mi gente sin
embargo hay un país que ha optado por
una solución intermedia ni prohibir lo
ni dejarlo como está qué tal si lo
regulamos y de qué país estamos hablando
os voy a dar una pista hablamos de él en
uno de los vídeos con más visitas de
visual política lo habéis adivinado ya
hablamos de
[Música]
[Aplausos]
la kriptonita ción recordáis este vídeo
que hicimos sobre suiza es uno de los
primeros vídeos que hicimos en este
canal allá por el año 2016 cuando yo
todavía tenía pelo en ese vídeo
hablábamos de un cantón el cantón de
zoom que es el que tiene los impuestos
más bajos de todo suiza pues a que no
adivina es donde tienen la sede nuestros
buenos amigos de etéreo
tener a la empresa más grande de cripto
divisas en tu país no olvidéis que
bitcoin no es una empresa significa que
tienes a los mayores expertos en la
materia así que casi todas las chicos se
hacen desde servidores suizos y
enseguida el gobierno de este país se
dio cuenta de que con o sin estafas
hablamos de un negocio millonario
quizá quiere ser la capital mundial de
las cripto monedas cuatro de las diez
chicos más grandes realizadas el año
pasado se hicieron en suiza más que en
ningún otro país para que os hagáis una
idea en algunas localidades suizas ya se
pueden pagar impuestos o incluso multas
en cripto monedas
que ni siquiera tiene 30.000 habitantes
es ya el hogar de más de 400 empresas de
block change y el gobierno regional ya
está empezando a hacer pruebas para usar
esta tecnología en su referéndum ya
sabéis que los referéndums suizos son
una de las bases de su sistema político
pues bien ahora quieren hacerlos
utilizando block change y por supuesto
suiza también quiere ser pionera en
regular la siglos
la autoridad financiera suiza presenta
las líneas maestras de su regulación de
las hijos por ejemplo cualquier empresa
que quiera realizar una eco en suiza
tendrá que hacerlo a través de una
empresa suiza eso implica que tendrán
que registrarse dar su nombre y tener
una dirección física de esta forma es
mucho más fácil perseguir a los
terroristas o narcotraficantes que
quieren lavar su dinero como os podéis
imaginar estas regulaciones ya han
surtido su efecto y muchas empresas del
sector se están marchando a otros
paraísos fiscales donde no hay ningún
tipo de regulaciones por ejemplo las
islas cayman ya le están haciendo la
competencia a suiza en lo que a eco se
refiere
pero ese es el precio a corto plazo para
tener un entorno estable hablamos de un
mundo que todavía necesita mucho para
ser un mercado maduro pero que podría
tener muchísimas posibilidades mucho más
allá que las estafas el blanqueo de
dinero o los pelotazos personalmente
creo que la postura de suiza es la más
inteligente llega una nueva tecnología
tiene muchos riesgos pero también muchas
oportunidades en lugar de prohibirla o
por el contrario dejarla completamente
libre lo ideal es regular la así nos
evitamos lo malo y nos quedamos con lo
bueno y por cierto volviendo a nuestros
amigos rusos esos que querían financiar
un establo con vacas a partir de cripto
monedas siento deciros quién no han
recaudado el dinero que necesitaban y
han tenido que cerrar el proyecto
[Música]
por desgracia dado que 1000 coin sólo ha
conseguido un 2 por ciento de los
objetivos vamos a devolver toda la
financiación que recibimos empezaremos a
devolverlo el 21 de noviembre gracias a
todos los que nos apoyaron y ahora la
pregunta es creéis que otros países
seguirán el ejemplo de suiza está claro
que todavía falta mucho tiempo para que
el mercado de las chicos madure pero
creéis que puede ser una auténtica
revolución financiera que permita que
todo el mundo independientemente de
donde viva pueda llegar a crear su
propia empresa
podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios y como siempre no olvidéis
que sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las
semanas así que suscribiros a visual
política y darle a la campanita para no
perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones si os ha gustado este
vídeo dadle a like compartirlo con
vuestros amigos y nos vemos en el
próximo un abrazo y hasta pronto
[Música]
[Aplausos]